Morris tell us a little about the new
series The Best Man the final chapters
and what's going on with your character
yeah you're the best man to final
chapters so uh the series opens up which
kind of how where the movie ends to
where there's possibly going to be a
wedding but with my character in
particular I'm just going through some
changes you know I lost my wife in the
last film and I'm trying to find my
purpose so I'm doing a lot to try to
find my purpose I'm trying to find my
way in life now that my rock is uh is
gone yeah so what about you guys tell us
about tell us all about your characters
I'm the best man
um my character is kind of struggling
with where he's going next in life he's
had some Commercial Success with his
writing and uh he's he's concerned with
being taken more seriously uh they they
the writers dig uh deeper into our
personal relationships so that was fun
yeah yeah how about you yeah what about
you Nia oh so Jordan is
I think she's achieved everything that
she's always dreamed of in terms of her
career
and
um she's at that crossroads where she's
kind of saying to herself is that enough
is this all I want is this all I need
and do I need to slow down and focus
more on self-care and self-love and try
to find some balance in her life did you
go through that when you turned 65 just
this past I did
I'm in therapy for it now you look
amazing
oh my God that's wrong
my character is still in her 20s so
no but um no Shelby oh gosh Porsche
she's a mess sorry Shelby is no but this
time Shelby I think people are going to
like her I you know I hope I accomplish
this but you know being that I've lost
everyone I've lost the man I've lost you
know but I became the self-made woman
and this time you're gonna see you're
going to see Shelby's heart you're going
to see a little bit of heart
um and you're just gonna we're gonna
peel off those layers we're gonna let
down the walls and and um maybe she'll
find love I won't tell you but maybe she
will
if not I like the hope and that Regina
what about you
uh well my husband played by Harold
parano who's not here I think they're
just kind of going through they have uh
stuff with their children children are
teenagers now going through
stuff
[Laughter]
so now it's captivating actually
but it's the stuff that I didn't go
through you know what I mean or there
weren't names for per se but it's
different nowadays with social media so
the kids have that extra you know piece
of anxiety so it's trying to figure out
that and then
um oh you know she's a professional
student so she's back in school to get
her PhD and then and then and then and
then dealing with stuff she and
I don't want this one getting mad you
know she gets jealous because she had
Julian first I did
we got him but we made up we made up
we're good we're good yeah we're good
so kind of like what's happening you
know and then you know marriages
marriages that can have crises
you did
well I know we fought about it right
right right right but I think right I
mean
ended up well right yeah okay girl oh my
God
this code this code shot is amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]